but because of that and then so let's
say I misunderstood and then we used to
fight in the kitchen you remember our
last fight was in the kitchen about the
pool but rice balls about okay it's not
rice balls and nobody says poo poo is on
a menu somewhere
no [ __ ] balls [ __ ] balls that's right
before all this started right so that
was probably I put a negative yeah which
you see this is what she used to say I'm
just saying the Asians in her
neighborhood growing up in South Philly
right used to pick [ __ ] balls what he
called them [ __ ] balls they were little
gingko somebody sent me a thing I think
it's ginkgo balls they grow on trees and
they really truly smell like hardcore
sewer [ __ ] and we would play football if
we got it on our clothes
my mother would lose her [ __ ] she was
like just burn your clothes outside she
hated she hated it and so it for years
they were like don't play the [ __ ] balls
are out there yeah so we had a fight we
would play football tackle football on
cement because we couldn't go on the
grass because the ship [ __ ] balls so one
day we saw all these Asian Lee and he's
picking it up so I was like I don't know
I'm an Irish kid living in an
all-italian neighborhood yeah all I know
are meatballs possibly I don't know
anything yeah and I go over and I'm like
what do you oh we make a soap right okay
but now what she's telling me this right
I don't know what kind of in my head
it's an attack on me of course right
because I'm sitting there I don't hear
it affects me as it is right
you hear it she's talking about it your
people eat [ __ ] ball
right and I'm like what I've never heard
of that [ __ ] right and I'm like that's
an attack of my [ __ ] heritage [ __ ] I
[Music]
was on the phone one time with my dad
and I was telling him about Bobby we
were human to each other and I was like
he's Korean and he goes north or south
girl calm down so then years and then
after that just we just years just quiet
like silence wait because to me like I
said he evaporated
yeah to me she existed like I would see
her in the hallway and I'd have to make
hate that I'm sorry yeah in my head I
had to go gotta go around go around not
and ads every almost every night because
I was a waitress there for 12 years they
should close you ever hang out with no
oh my god yeah we shut down yeah she
shut down old I evaporated yeah he could
have been in the hallway to me that was
just a ghost
he felt like I swear to god she would
even have conversations with people that
are friends about the weave right like a
few is there I've been talking to you
yeah I know
it went on it was but it's 20 years that
fence but then I I left for a year and
came back after Friday passed as a comic
which is even worse for him I didn't
know he had all this stuff picked up
yeah yeah I was just like okay let me
get better at stand-up but avoid
I wasn't a regular so I was just doing
you wouldn't come in on those nights
that mostly I was there yeah but I would
wha I swear to God a couple of times I'd
say I knew you're on stage and I would
go into CEO and that in my head I'm like
please bomb like he's not I'm not and
then when she and then when she would
get a laugh it would ruin my whole week
he would stab us it would devastate me
I'd be laying in bed like dear God
please give her lung cancer like I hated
her that I'm being real right now
yeah no and I appreciate yeah yeah but
then when I became a cop I was like okay
I'm gonna be professional because to me
I was raised technically by mitzi in the
comedy store yeah where it was a comedy
store not the late restorer let me give
you [ __ ] about the wait staff for the
door guy the comics were important so
it's he was a hierarchy technically so
I'm like [ __ ] with that in my head so
one time he came in to do it I was
hosting open mic and he came in to do a
spot oh gosh and I was so nervous
and I think I mentioned every single
thing you've ever done like it was
almost overboard and epithelia Ari
Shaffir and you hadn't made up yet
sitting in the audience so you know it's
so imagine though I let me see something
it's all based we have a commercial
break what is a who's a sponsor and we
do have a sponsor and that is 23